wait wait I want to get a good shot
ready go 1 2 3 right it's bright and
early day it's time to be a doctor okay
such an aggressive all right let's take
this little guy for a walk you ready
let's go play that ping right on the
grate to not make a mess I trained him
well you can't see the Empire State
Building it's right there
touch it touch it as any veteran dog
owner will tell you one of the biggest
struggles of having a plug is when
you're walking them in the morning you
want to get to work your dog refuses to
poo
Perico Poole my first patient today is
extra at 8:00 a.m. but I want to get in
a little earlier to start working on my
notes from the other day notes are the
bane of the existence of the doctor
because not only do we want to see the
patient spend time with them then we
become slaves to the electronic medical
record
it's very brutal what is that there you
want to put that away
let's get to work
today I'm going to be working a long 12
14-hour shift as an outpatient a family
medicine doctor now what does outpatient
mean it means that I'm gonna be seeing
patients in an office setting where I
don't have to admit them meaning that
they are not going to stay overnight in
the hospital so it's basically when you
go in for your doctor's visit for a
check-up or a problem that's what I'm
going to be doing today that's primarily
actually what I do so today we'll
probably have around 30 patients where
maybe after each visit I'll come and
tell you what I did and we can have a
little learning opportunity as if they
oh my god a major fail when I see
patients in my office I see them for
anything acute problems meaning like
they get sick today or they have pain
today or something's going on where it's
an urgent matter but I also see them for
primary care meaning that they're coming
in for chronic disease management
counseling so I have diabetic patients
that need to check their numbers make
sure they're taking their medications
optimally it's a really fun job because
you really never know what's gonna
happen if you don't know what kind of
patients gonna walk in it God if you
guys didn't know any better you would
have thought I got into an accident my
commute isn't that
it's around 45 minutes it's a reverse
commute some people are like wait you
work in New Jersey but live in New York
yeah
that's actually a great strategy because
I do a lot of TV stuff in New York so I
have to be here but that I love work in
New Jersey because that's where I did my
residency training and I built up this
patient panel of patients I actually
love and have a connection with them
growing old with them but it's kind of
funny to say I think we got some great
content cutting I wonder by the way now
that we're just hanging out here having
supporter and I'm driving to work I need
you to hit that subscribe button and
that notification velvety and set your
alerts to all just so that YouTube
algorithm does the best with us any
further
I know only 15% of you have done that so
far and step up your game you can do
better
hey dinosaur occasion
who's excited for a work are you excited
for work Jenny isn't it a great day to
save lives I'm gonna sit on this garbage
can here sit on the garbage no I'm gonna
sit in the garbage can he'll tell me
what to do you're not my mom maybe my
work mom what's the craziest thing
you've ever seen
you making me think back here yeah
people that have passed and there's a
smile appears on their face within
seconds of them totally dancing away
that's pretty amazing any good stories
Jenny let's cheer people up Mikkel good
stories is there's lots of men walking
around with nice grumps
I'm the mess story Jenny's getting
feisty today
okay what about Ireland's talk about on
the blog why not okay
INR is when a patient comes in for a
test to see if they're taking their
cumin and properly and appropriately so
let's check it out so when you're
looking at an INR what I'm looking at is
to figure out a is the patient's dosage
correct B are they coming in at the
right intervals so if their levels are
all over the place and we can't get any
stability we have to figure out why
that's happening and we have to check
them more often but if they're
consistently having good numbers we can
spread them out
represent represent Oh
today's a Hospital vlog day baby you
ready for I'm ready
you can try to get Liddy I'm writing I'm
ready to get Liddy yo you got a big
shade up DJ I want to hear that I get
thon all right I got $10 that I get come
on come on it's a party I always say how
many patients you check-in it right now
you don't think you're worth it
all right go do your job because I need
to see my patients so my typical day
goes like this I come in
I try and catch up on the computer to
call patients back to look at results to
write some notes that I missed the
previous day and then I go in and every
15 20 minutes I have a new patient I'm
in and out of the rooms I've been either
was like I just came out of a room with
the patient was complaining about really
bad allergies that's really interesting
because the typical pollen season is now
over now we're getting into that
wintertime allergy season and sometimes
if you're using the same allergy
medication for too long you can actually
build up a tolerance to it you need to
rotate them so what we're doing for this
patient is we're changing up the allergy
medications we're also giving
medications directly from where the
symptoms are present so you think about
the nose the eyes and we're really
trying to get them better by thinking
big picture because it's not enough to
just think about prevention we also need
to think about treating the active
symptoms today's gonna be a busy day but
I'm excited to get started so I just
have to call a patient back for his
ultrasound he came in with gynecomastia
which is he had a breast mess basically
breast tissue developing and when we do
that we have to check hormonal levels if
those hormonal levels are elevated then
we got to do an ultrasound if the
ultrasound is negative then we got to do
a cat scan if that's negative then we
know something so it's really
interesting how we have to follow these
sets of guidelines so that we don't do
extra testing and we don't do under
testing it's a very fine line that we
have to follow here what's going on
you want to tell the peeps if you get
any crazy calls and people asking to
come see me no can I help you no we
don't deal with that here sorry
somewhat doctors to agreed here hello hi
is an expert in everything when it comes
to mental health ah
I've taught me everything I know I talk
a lot about anxiety and depression on my
channel how rates are going up is that
something you've noticed there is a lot
more sort of tension it's a large
surrounding environment of the country
these days and those things of course
impact patients lives and people who are
susceptible to developing significant
anxiety anxiety disorders as we say so
yes there's more of it and it's
affecting youth as well alright cuz I
got a really long day I only get to once
before I get home which is gonna be
around like 10 p.m. that picked up some
Chipotle idea what are you gonna tell me
you're gonna tell me about a public
patient who is here for an employee
physical we do that here right yes we do
that and what do we do generally for
those patients we just make sure they
could breathe and they have a pulse what
what is it see it made you because no
one could answer this question oh okay
well generally it's a medical assistant
so I'm still able to like nurse it back
in the day bring patients and do vital
signs draw blood give injections and
assists what proceed
like skin biopsy tone our we gave the
greatest answer so far you're a rock
star yeah so I just had a pretty
interesting patient encounter patients
coming in for an earache
I looked through the patient's notes and
she's been here a lot and I see that
she's been diagnosed with cancer was
familiar to me so I looked back in my
notes and I found that I saw this
patient about a year ago and it was
actually me who caught the cancer I
didn't know this when I walked into the
room the patient was basically in tears
because she was happy to see me because
I was the one that initially got the
x-ray to find her cancer because what
happened was she had pneumonia it did an
x-ray but then when you get her
pneumonia the way it shows up on an
x-ray can actually cover the cancer if
there is a cancer or anything there
that's why whatever person gets better
we asked them to come back in for a
follow-up x-ray to make sure that
there's nothing behind in pneumonia and
what do you know she was still a little
bit coughing month went by I said let's
get another x-ray boom there was
something else there ended up getting a
cat scan a few days later we found a
cancer that was treated now she's doing
great
but now for her to come in for an
earache and be doing well after being
diagnosed treated and her being really
happy she tells me something really cute
she says my kids especially the little
one are such big fans of yours I said
because of you just like no because you
saved my life
I said all how old is your little one
like thirty nine we have one of our
staff members that's been here for
almost a decade and a half so we're
gonna go say goodbye to her but she's
not ready to surprise
[Applause]
love you that we're trying to teach
everybody how to be healthy and happy
and what are you doing what are you
doing here I didn't eat cake I didn't I
didn't eat no cake look at that what is
this yeah okay I didn't have cake a
little tired it's past 8 p.m. we started
this day at 6:00 I'm almost there to
tell him just so you understand the
struggle that a doctor has to go through
like I've worked on stop pretty much all
day for these 1213 hours whatever I
worked but my notes are null does so I
either have to sit at my desk finishing
these notes or I have to go home do them
at home or tomorrow morning wake up
extra early before I started doing my
other stuff and do the notes so as you
can see burnout can start happening very
soon and very easily for physicians so
the struggle is real but it's worthwhile
struggle
Evette I'm scared I don't want to get
the flu shot gives you the flu it does
all this bad stuff I don't want it
betta kiddo usually a mask oh oh oh
Lucy who you like some cold spray first
I don't but do I want cold spray no I'm
already cold as is it will numb the area
I wish I weren't under shirt today for
the video she said no heavy lifting
better why I want a heavy lift no no no
irritation Jesse please some type of
discomfort no temperature you can take
take drinks happening moving this pop
it's happening take the pressure off for
your little game I free so you can just
sit up a little bit
there's so much you Danny here wait wait
I want to get a good shot are you ready
go 1 2 3 oh oh I'm just kidding it
doesn't hurt it actually feels good it
feels like a relief because I'm no
longer gonna get the flu
well at least 40 to 60% of the time I
thought to walk out of the office
without my tie straight Magic Mike style
this is what happens when it's almost 10
p.m. do you know where your children are
vet yes where do you know where your
child is well at least you got 33% Oh a
long day in the office but we saved some
lives took care of business now I'm
gonna head home walk and feed the bear
maybe do some more work at home but
that's what a day in the hospital's like
boys and girls hope you enjoyed